so on Thursday I had a 9 o'clock lecture
so early start
walked lectures had a lecturer in the
Dennis Wilkinson building on theoretical
physics in particular we were looking at
start of group theory which we haven't
done in this course yet but we were
looking at the basics of it and then
we're gonna be applying that to
classical field theory in the next
couple of lectures after that walk backs
and Peter's check my page check the JCR
to see if I could find any excuse not to
work and then went to the library I
worked in library from 10:00 till
approximately 12:00 working on the
theory problem sheet for this week which
on that morning in particular was
looking at many particle quantum systems
so looking assistants of fermions and
using creation and annihilation
operators on fox base then had lunch
with some friends when I had a lunch
which looked like this and my friends
had a dessert which look like this and
oh my god that's ice cream and Oreos on
a cake why did not not go for that and
then headed back to the library in the
afternoon I was working on more theory
and then switched over to some
atmospheric physics because I get bored
of working on the same thing over and
over again
I actually got so bored of working on
that that there then went to the corner
shop and picked up some treats please
don't judge me I know I shouldn't be
doing it so then works in the library
overall from about one o'clock til 5
o'clock then that evening we had a
physic Society event where we went to
dinner with the speaker this week he was
Professor Steven blundell who I was
lucky enough to be lectured by in my
second year on thermodynamics we had a
lovely dinner on little Clarendon Street
in Oxford in a restaurant called Pierre
Victoire
and it was just a really nice relaxed
kind of atmosphere it was so strange to
be sat next to this universally
acclaimed professor who's he's written
textbooks and you know it was like an
idol of mine on Western year in my
second year and just be savvy ben-hur
and chatting about things as inane as
like voice recognition on series so then
after that we went to his talk at the
physics society and he was giving a talk
entitled the north/south divide how
magnetism has repeatedly revolutionized
the world which was a very interesting
talk he in particular the reason I like
his textbook in particular was because
he always focused on the historical
aspect of the science
his thermal physics textbook actually
gave you a biography at the end of each
chapter about a key player in that
chapter so learning about whether
Maxwell fully a Boltzmann Einstein you
know all these people and that was the
slum that he took on this talk showing
how magnetism shaped our physical
understanding but looking at the human
stories behind it he also has written a
very short introduction and oxford
university press which is something I'd
recommend checking out because I won't
be like him then after the talk headed
back to some Peters picked up some
necessary supplies in Sainsbury's and
then headed to the library this time it
was nice because I was being joined by
my friend Dan who's a for theatres maths
and we were both in the lower library
which I liked working in at the moment
because the freshers don't know it
exists yet and it's just a place for
crumby for Fears
like me and dan you don't like freshers
he just lets us work in peace
although mitad lee this time we weren't
really working in peace we were actually
working with music blaring on his laptop
which was kind of nice it was different
I had a problem she to problem she's
doing on Friday the next day so I was
working down there till about three
o'clock in the morning only looking at
mysteric physics that night just trying
to plow through this stuff it's not the
case I'm living em to the last minute
I'm working consistently throughout the
week but at the moment I'm much more
concerned about my understanding the
material than actually getting
everything right on a problem sheet so
if I have the choice between taking
texts with notes and understanding the
material of rushing I'll answer could
can be able to move on to the next
question the problem sheet or I always
choose the former because that's what's
gonna help me in the long run as a
consequence it means that there's almost
always a mad rush at the end of problems
you but that's the price you pay I think
for prioritizing long term understanding
it was short term gain so yeah I left
the library
very late came out to my room and slept
I think that's enough excitement for one
day raining not enough sleep
who's this up